that's a g's chord guys but it's in a
standard d
tuning welcome to the corridor digital
podcast and uh sam and i are gonna take
it away ready sam
ready
[Music]
standard chords but they're a little bit
lower than you've heard
that's because it makes the song a
little darker
guys wow welcome back i mean that is not
my best intro but it's also not my worst
so i will take it
um listen people have been asking about
the banjo lately and i gotta say
um it's right over there and that thing
is very intimidating um i've been trying
to learn more
uh but in between um you know
making videos you know there's there's a
slice of time plus i got that civil war
novel that i got to get through so you
know yeah
there's only so much time in in the day
a man can spend learning banjo
i hear it's easier when you drink a
bunch of pbr first
yeah well that's what the coors light is
for so he's working his way up
mm-hmm there's not a lot of time to
learn it and
honestly these days not not a lot of
places to play it
yeah that's true you could play it
actually i saw some guys playing it on
the streets of seattle and they were
pretty good i bought one of their
records
oh nice little street record player
yeah uh sorry one of their cds they were
called the um
oh man i wish i could remember the 100
year old men
no no i have to look it up they were
the 100 year old men no they were called
the uh they played this really funny
song
banjo boys and the bingo bongos yeah
it was basically that um i can't
remember their name they're they were
great
yeah i want to give out their the name
of their band because
it's they had a really great song but
i'll i'll do it later
i'll do it when you guys are talking
about something else i'll look it up was
this just in like the streets of texas
somewhere
or no this was on the streets of seattle
oh
yeah and um in uh uh
fisher what is that place called oh the
fisherman wharf or whatever yeah
yeah the crab village
no they don't look like right there on
the bay and stuff yeah the tourists the
tourist attractions bike market a pike
market or something
um so anyways who do we got today
we got we got sam as always
right yeah sam okay i'm the old standby
and then i guess we both are
and then we got christian yep yep i'm
here also
as well yep most unfortunately no we got
everybody in the house today we're
mixing it up
um so nat you're in the new studio
i am welcome how do you feel about it
uh i get a corner that's all i asked for
i just wanted a corner so can you move
that camera at all can they can the
people
yeah show the people what they want to
see yeah sure at all
windows here's a window black rectangles
here's yeah man we need some art in
there
look oh well i got i i have some art
that's why she wanted that corner you
know
yeah we do need to decorate it did you
make that art
absolutely not it's by a artist named
conrad rosa i am
unfortunately not talented in that
specific realm
because well you're pretty talented with
building stuff i mean
that's how we originally started working
with you was uh through
fabrication prop building yep yeah
um i feel like that's something we
should get back to
you know to do uh prop making yeah like
i mean
well think about it like the node
channel right so if you guys don't know
nat's been
brought in to run things on node and
we've been working with her for
i mean how long has it been now almost
half a year at this point
yeah wow so
you know everything we're doing on that
channel there's i feel like there's an
element
where we could bring in some more
experimentation with stuff like building
insane props and stuff that would be
really fun for people
yeah and i mean i i think in some ways
like i've tried
to do that like the the one button
controllers and
pinewood derby and stuff like that but
yeah
when you're making two videos a week
it's uh kind of hard to also bounce out
like a
a really really great invention here's
an idea here's an idea for that
okay we do nodes great inventions or
maybe it's just nat's great inventions
and we do it on
uh we do it on the website and then
um we we get the money together
from the subscribers we greenlight it
get these points in there
yeah to make a crazy whatever we want to
make
and then we drop the episode on the
website and then after it's been on the
website for like maybe a month or
longer then we drop it on youtube or we
tease it on
youtube so i mean we've kind of sort of
done that i've built a few things on the
website
at this point and uh we made a little
little video about it so
if you want to see me building a fight
stick that's i did do that
yeah but this is that was like you know
that was like the seedling of the idea
now i'm talking about you know yeah how
how tall can we build this town well i
have a bunch of things that i want to
build
if you want to pay for them jake i'm
absolutely actually it's the people
we need those producer points back to me
it's all up to the people
okay okay okay corridor fans
i would like i would like to build a
one-to-one
replica of the bride sword from kill
bill with every single individual detail
all imported from japan all the correct
parts so
contribute contribute all your points to
uh this idea that we're definitely going
to put on the green light page
immediately
and i will i will build that sword and i
will i will
out film hold like wield it i really
like that idea i mean it seems totally
over the top and unnecessary
but at the same time maybe we could give
it to somebody really really cool well
and it's a good exploration into like
movie prop film you know prop making and
film
it's like that's really cool to see it
come together
um sam do you have any swords that
you've really wanted to build
i mean i know you're you're a man you're
you're a blade man yeah i am but not not
not i don't know not not nothing swords
like i used to be i'm more into the
exotics
i mean you got me into swords and you
got me into blades
swords are cool i mean but you know you
start going for the blunt weapons
and axes and stuff like that it's kind
of become my jam
these days the ones that really you know
make an impact
not not just the simple slice but the
ones that get really messy
yeah well make stuff that you hold when
you're filming you're taking your
like metal album like photo cover you
know like
like those ones like we'll make a we'll
make sam
a norse mjolnir just to just to like
wheel around and bust desks i mean
freeze
that would be pretty sweet that'd be uh
you keep that in your car
we're gonna
maybe one you know like a four pound
hammer like one that's like not too
heavy
you know maybe like a six pound when we
were in texas
we were we we bought like what couple
thousand
dollars worth of medieval weapons that
are just
sitting in jake's garage or something
yeah yeah it's still there
like we're going through them all
they're all really cool but there's this
one that's just like stupid because it's
like a steel
pipe with like a like a welded
like just this five or ten pound
ball on the end there's no spikes it's
just a
steel ball on a pipe with a leather
handle and it was just like fascinating
because i borrowed that from a guy there
there's this guy named his his nickname
is
knox uh and uh he he
has a small um like fabrication
sort of you know situation going on in
his garage
and around the side of his house he's
got a forge a mini forge
oh yeah of course of course so yeah so
he
he i believe he made that himself i
don't i don't know if he actually made
the uh the metal but he he bought the
metal and then he turned it into
that he welded it and he and he polished
it and he ground it down and
he made that whole thing um because he
makes some of his other swords and stuff
too
don't tell him what i did with it then
see the thing is no i see i when i first
met him
so uh so sam we're i'll tell this i'll
tell what you do with it first and then
i'll tell why that doesn't work yeah i
need to know this like you can't just
you can't just say that and then like
you can leave me a little loop
sam was really excited to have it in her
hand i mean i just got it and i started
like grunting like a caveman and i
we were outside and so i started like
grunting and i just like walked up
swinging
and i just started like beating trees
with this thing as hard as i could
yeah dent them all i mean didn't do much
of the trees it's like a blunt weapon
it's not gonna cut down a tree but and
then jordan started filming us
jordan started filming us on her phone
and then i and then i walked up with a
stick and we started acting like monkeys
like
around a tree going like yeah
it was great though yeah it was but it
seems like it could take the beating it
didn't
not oh no i'm gonna scratch on it that
thing was solid for sure
so that's what i mean because he all the
stuff that this guy gave to me
i originally i i so i'll tell the story
um
we were gonna film this medieval piece
and i'm not in texas we were gonna film
it out here
so i'm new to the area so i called up
our buddy adam lyons and i was like hey
um do you know
you know you were robin hood at the at
the
sherwood festival fair so you know who
who do you know that can help
us put this together so he calls
a couple of buddies and he puts me in
touch with them and he's like okay
you're gonna go see this guy knox
uh and i show up and i'm like i drove
all the way to round rock which is like
an hour and a half away from here
and uh i show up at his house at like 8
30 in the morning or nine in the morning
and uh he's like hey and i'm like hey um
so you got the stuff and he's like yeah
i got some stuff and
we walk up to this room he's got
and he's got this whole room with like
suits of
armor and like all this leather working
stuff and it's just like his little
playhouse
um and he's got this giant suit of armor
and i'm being really
dainty with everything because i don't
know like i don't know him and it's like
all looks really expensive and it looks
like he put a lot of hard time and money
and work into it but
the thing about a lot of those guys
especially the guys that make stuff
their self
themselves they want to have it hold up
to hardship uh so they'll they'll make
it with pads
all the stuff that he built he built for
himself he can put it on with a full
underneath uh armoring cloak and he's
got all the layers and he's got all the
padding on the inside and so they'll
take those aluminum swords and they'll
hate each other like like you know full
larp
action i don't know if it's like full
like you know you killed my brother
full but it's it's it's hard so hard
that some of it's some of the armor that
he had is dented
um oh man yeah you've seen battle yeah
i legit am kind of jealous of like the
people who get into like jousting
as a as a hobby because like they're
just like out there in full armor they
they have like
that plate there but if you miss like
that's like
that's like real armor and you have to
have it bounce off it's
really cool yeah yeah no totally and and
he's one of those guys he i believe he's
not jousting anymore because he's i
think he's in his 50s
but yeah but up until like he was in his
late 40s he was still
jousting um on horseback
does he take commissions uh like
for like if sam wants to get a
custom-made something if i want to if i
want to custom
rod and ball probably so
the guy the guy that's what they're
called they're called bangers right
yeah they're just bangers hey can i uh
i think it's a mace right mace without
the spikes technically
technically it's like a blood it's like
a blunt mace
um so again we've done like three
medieval shoots and every time we do a
medieval shoot i learned more and more
and more
um but uh yeah he might be able to hook
you up man i mean he's
he's a medical guy during the day he
does like
radiology and stuff so um
he yeah he's he's out there curing
cancer when he's not pushing people off
horses
uh it's pretty pretty what a character
yeah
um is this the guy that lives in the or
like works out of a castle
so yeah so that's the guy that owns uh
the sherwood forest fair and he is also
uh an amazing dude um
i'll just i'll tell we're telling
stories i'll tell a little story about
him so
he uh so adam put me in touch with him
and then he's like yeah so
he's the guy with the armory um that
owns the armory the sword shop
that i bought all those swords from so i
had to go buy all these swords because
we needed to light some on fire
and we needed to cut some in half and
again
i went to this guy's sword shop and he's
got like real ones which
they call sharps and he's got uh
aluminum ones which
you know they just i don't know what
they call those uh fighting or
stage swords um so uh
i'm going through this inventory and i'm
like i wonder if i should tell this guy
that i'm gonna like cut one of these in
half
and i was like i mean so you know
so i kind of ask like so how durable are
these things like we want to light one
of them on fire do you think
like that would be you know do you think
how do you think it would take it and
he's like oh hey they're your swords man
once you buy them true that
so then uh i got into the whole like
detail of exactly like okay we want to
cut this one here
you know we want to light this one on
fire it's going to have to be handheld
it's going to have to be
tall and flaming um and he was awesome
and then um the other day uh when i went
to return the stuff i went to his house
and uh
uh like near round rock also
and um he lives in this like giant
stone house on a river
um and i walk it yeah i walk in and like
uh
he's he's got like this giant atrium
that has uh this this this oak
like paneling on the top and like uh
what do you call it uh crown
crown molding and uh then there were
these double doors that opened up to
the river and it like leads down this
gentle hill and then this this couple
comes walking up with a with a raven
and and and this guy's like holding a
rape like no
the bird like just a giant yeah
and there's like this kid with a dog and
there's like
he i didn't know he was gay his
husband's right there and he's like hey
this is my husband because he had kids
so i just assumed but and he's i'm like
cool
and then this person comes walking up
with a raven and this dog comes up to me
and
i'm like in this i'm immediately
immersed in like a medieval castle
wonderland but there's like
a there's like a good crossover between
people who are way too into medieval
things
and like goth people who happen to own
ravens
so i'm pretty sure that's just like the
intersection oh yeah and then gay people
are like
kind of like within that circle too it
was the intersection of
and i was like man you guys are just
living the dream down here like you
and then the raven okay so then they
they had the raven and then the dog and
the raven cast the spell never even
started talking to you
okay so the raven can talk wait oh my
god
yeah the raven can like mimic mimic
words
like a parrot and then the raven got
scared because the dog
like kind of you know like charged it or
whatever
and the raven was on a leash it was on
one of those like expandable
uh dog leashes and and then the raven
the dog
snapped and the raven like flew up into
a tree
and then uh and then it flew off and
they were like oh crap the raven's gone
again
and uh apparently it's happened before
and so then
we had you know i delivered the stuff
and and i was there for a little while
and then like
the the girl that owns the raven was
like hey so um i'm i think i'm gonna
call animal control because like maybe
somebody picked him up or something or
maybe somebody saw a talking raven
it seems like a pretty rare thing so
then they call they call animal control
and they're like
hey uh uh you know i gotta just ask
uh you you didn't happen to come across
a talking raven did you
and they're like oh yeah he's here with
us
we found him what yeah
what it was situation yeah and then they
went and picked up the raven
it was so who turns in a
talking raven to animal control that's
insane i i think somebody called and
then
you know they were like hey this ravens
obviously got an owner
talking in my garden yeah there's this
bird's talking like typically i wouldn't
call about a regular ravens hello
there's an ominous bird in my backyard
screaming things at me
i'm really really afraid yeah it was oh
my god
that's the moment at which like the
animal control control guys like
go out to the to the mission and then
they they're they're like the ones who
get killed first in the horror movie
right yeah totally by the talking raven
um so that was an experience and i just
like and then they've been super cool
like uh the guy that owns the fair
has just been amazing he's like yeah if
ever you guys want to come out here and
film if you ever you
you know you want to borrow anything if
you need a standing army
of uh you know of people we'll get it
together
um so let's get it together let's get it
that sounds awesome um yeah they've just
been super cool and uh i definitely want
to do something big with them because
um why not sounds like an awesome
resource to have
yeah good connection well i know what
i'm doing next summer
i'm riding the freaking medieval shore
we're going to texas
we're going to the freaking texas
renaissance fair that's what we're doing
oh nice
yo in there and so he started an ale
company that they sell at the fair
and apparently the ale company is
blowing up right now and so
basically there's we have free mead if
uh damn it
if we want to go gosh damn it what's the
name don't threaten me with the good
time
um it is called uh
let me look real quick i've never been
to a red fair i don't want to get it
right down to try to check it out
oh dang it's a it's a visual experience
christian i know i mean everyone down
here is actually pretty good i've heard
tons of stories from carmichael and sam
and stuff i would
i mean that sounds like my childhood
dream so i would totally be down
it's super fun and you will regret it if
you don't dress up oh no i gotta go
full on you gotta do something it's
called thorin's
mead thoren's mead this is the guy
that that also has the cast on all this
stuff he started a mead company
yes you're telling me you're telling me
we could get mead
probably shipped to the studio on like a
monthly basis
and we're not taking advantage of this
whatsoever
listen you know i i didn't even think of
that but now that you've brought it up i
feel like i'm obligated she wants some
promotion of the mead man let's work it
in let's figure it
out yep that's what that's the reason
yeah exactly
help dude that sounds awesome yeah
hello everyone it's that time in the
episode where i tell you about today's
sponsor storyblocks if you've been
listening to this podcast you already
know they sponsor this podcast all the
time and you don't need to thank me
okay thank them for making this podcast
possible because without them
we wouldn't be able to do this or at
least not as much let me tell you a
little bit about them let's just let me
get your ear for a second first and
foremost
storybox is the one stop shop for
creators and businesses alike when
they're looking for
a complete unlimited list of stock
elements to use in all their projects
and videos now what does that mean
it means that they have images they have
video they have audio assets
they have motion graphic assets they've
got high quality 4k
across their entire library they're
constantly updating it so you never have
to worry about searching for
one thing using that footage and then
never being able to use story blocks
again
they've got all the little bells and
whistles that you're going to need when
you're editing a project and you get to
that point and you realize
oh i need a pick up shot for this check
out story blocks first it might save you
the time and the energy now the best
part about storyblocks is that they have
an
unlimited all-access plan which allows
you to download as much as you want from
their site whenever you want and to use
it
in all different manner and sorts of
content that means whether it's a
youtube video that you're monetizing
or even if you're making something for
another client and it's going to be in a
commercial or something like that you
can use
storyblocks for that purpose that's the
best part that's why we love them at
corridor digital not only
does it save our business hours but it
also just makes the whole process
of finding the right site for b-roll and
other stock assets
a heck of a lot more enjoyable head on
over to storyblocks.comcast to check it
out
the rest will take care of itself your
video will finish itself just head on
over there
drop in some footage and boom out comes
a video storyblocks.comcast once again
huge thanks to them for sponsoring can't
say enough good things about them
um should we get back to that podcast
now or
all right let's go seriously let's go so
so 2021 which leads me into the next
topic which is kind of what i wanted to
talk about but sam
i mean that could be on the table we
could do a medieval
uh piece and go to the rent fair
and go to the rent fair and then um
you know there's got to be a way to work
in like some tournament games
for node you know like we should show up
yeah dang i want to have you guys
jousting i want to i want to have you
guys learn to joust and like some guys
no we have to do all like the fun like
peasant games
yes yes
sam sam am i am i really doing my job if
i don't put you and nico
on horses with giant adjusting poles in
the armor
like i'm i'm pretty sure this is like
within the description of like
everything that i need to do yeah like
we have
full severing our spines and getting
concussions
we'll use like uh flexible
poles and then we'll put padding on them
so it'll be more like american ninja
warrior
you know let's just dress
you have to be on the horses okay and
then we'll paint we'll paint the
the um the lances to look to look a real
you know and and then it'll it'll look
all legit but
your chances of severely injuring
yourself be a little bit lower
like the filmmaking approach you know
safe but looks good
you know yeah the whole nine
yeah okay sounds good okay
okay and then we'll have a jousting
tournament
so we got jousting we've got obviously
there's axe throwing i mean that one's
kind of cliche
but r3 our archery classic yeah spear
throwing
we were gonna we were gonna have a no
archery competition eventually so
that's exciting yeah we should do spear
throwing
for sure that's something we've never
done
is pretty pretty fun and not just how
far you can throw it
but actually you know you hit a target
yeah like hit a target
like closest to those closest to the
bullseye with the javelin
instead no you yeah you got to do it
that way axe throw
those are good yeah and then just
straight up duels
and then just straight up one-on-ones
dude what about like is log rolling does
that
can we do log rolling and like armor
that's
i feel like that's uh that's more of
like a like a southern
kind of deal well technically it's a
lumberjack thing
yeah like an outdate it's like an
outdoor games kind of deal
i'm pretty sure okay so a buddy of mine
that i used to run track with in high
school
uh what used to be the log rolling chain
log rolling champ
yeah of all uh what you know
still no still chainsaws like sponsors
the
the the the national lumberjack
competition or whatever yeah and so he
was the champion of the whole of that
competition oh wow yeah um
but log rolling could be i mean
it sounds fun it sounds medieval
totally yeah i know a guy who's um one
of my uh
my neighbors from uh stillwater moved
to montana and then to alaska where he
got into timber sports professionals are
we talking about the same guy
i know you guys are talking about
probably not what was his
what was his name i'm talking about hank
johnson oh okay
no i'm talking about i'm talking about a
guy named aaron
he he's uh no i know he he moved to
alaska and then
somehow got big into timber sports which
is what it's called
yeah and timberspoons
henry growing up and then he moved away
from home and then found a new identity
in his hands
he became hank yeah yeah and so then
he somehow found himself like doing
actual logging in montana
and then ended up moving to alaska
because his real life logging experience
translated into timber sports prowess
and
now he professionally log rolls
and what climbs logs you do the climb
where you have the rope
how fast can you cut stuff yeah
and you cut you cut cookies off of uh
off of a giant log
and it's how fast you can get cut
through the cookie yeah you're gonna do
that with uh
with like the the back and forth saw too
yeah sure
yeah i mean you can do it like that too
but when when the pro leagues
they they use competitive grade
chainsaws
this is triple a this is triple a sports
here which are hilarious because it's
like i don't even know if you'd use a
competitive grade chainsaw in like real
life situations
for logging but i imagine if you're like
a really like
rich lager you have a personal golden
like
turbo powered chainsaw yeah sorry hey
gideon
special guest hi gideon hi
so okay so here's what we could do
natalie
we could take some of these concepts
like we take we take the idea
of sam and nico
enter a timber sports
tournament they they try to get as far
as they can
in a timber sport tournament and then we
put that
on the green light and then they we we
get is whatever we need
to spend to make that happen that's what
it costs on green light
if you can if you can get uh them on a
timber sports thing
it'd be fun to put up with your tough
mudder i'm just trying to think of all
of them
remember i could possibly break their
neck oh my god christian and i did tough
mudder and you've done the tough mudder
that was a miserable experience that was
probably one of the hardest physical
things i've ever done
so back back a few years ago um
sarah and clint and myself went to uh
the zombie race oh the zombie runs and
that was freaking crazy because they got
like
hundreds of extras basically as zombies
as you do like a 5k
and basically you start the race with
it's like flag football style where you
have three flags
on your belt and zombies around the
flags and
like the 100 zombies along the track
basically are all chasing you constantly
and so it's
it's very very very difficult so in
order to stay into the race you got to
make sure you're
keeping a pace where they're not
grabbing your flags yeah but but
like it's funny we did it like right
after dayz came out so we dressed up
like daisy characters with like pepsis
and stuff
um but the the difficult part about it
is yeah obviously escaping the zombies
but the stratos the strategy comes in
like
you're you're running with other people
so yeah you need to run fast but if you
can position yourself in the crowd
so that like you're not getting grabbed
get taken first
that's how you finish it um and so
you're always like trying to like
be like kind of like in the right
position in a crowd so that way when
people
get hunted down like there's people who
get weeded out first basically yeah
it's like uh like how do how to
it's like the whole like how to escape a
bear thing is yeah
get a slow friend yeah yeah you know
yeah
you don't get out right now the zombie
just the slowest person i feel like
you're being attacked by a zombie right
now
saying i i am
[Laughter]
it's going crazy i love how this podcast
is just us hanging out now
yeah yeah yeah um so wait when did you
guys do tough mudder
uh 71 actually it was like what does the
zombie say what does a zombie say
what is it what does a zombie say so
christian and i
go back yeah i mean that we've actually
been five years
yeah they've actually been working
together for the last five years or so
studio 71 and yeah it was just one of
those like corporate
team building things they were like the
company's going on a tough mudder yeah
and so you know you could sign up and we
all you know signed up and ran for
studio 71 and
yeah that was and uh i made it up the
first mountain and then i passed out of
dehydration because i was on
a diuretic at the time
which uh not not a no that sounds
different than it is it's a medication
that rids you of body water really
really quickly yeah
yeah so uh i immediately passed out and
then got
shuttled down the mountain and then they
were like do you do you just want to
like sit here for a while i'm like no
and i just jumped back in the race and
found christian randomly
oh yeah you did find me and yeah because
i was thinking about
the rest of it yeah i did finish it but
it was i was definitely not you know in
the
in the front of the back so so what did
you have to do
man well first of all it's like i think
a 5k
so it's the distance but then there's
obstacles throughout so
the first the first obstacle was that
you had to climb basically
an entire mountain yeah the first yeah
like the first huge grade
totally yeah the first checkpoint is
just a crazy incline
but like some of the main obstacles i
remember is like you climb up this
ladder and you're on this platform
that's probably 15 maybe 20 feet in the
air
and there's this just pool of water at
the bottom and you have to
jump and rope swing and like ring a bell
and then just
fall right into the water and then
there's like this big like wall run we
have to run up a ramp
and like get caught at the top and then
the one like only sketchy one that i
remember is like you're at the very end
there's always
yeah you get tased basically there's
like a bunch of wires hanging there's a
bunch of wires
circuits at the end there's literally
like one of the last obstacles is like
you're running
through like a a wet puddle which is
even wilder
to me and there's just these cords
hanging with like open circuits at the
bottom so when you're
running through it's just like tapping
it just tastes like over and over yeah
boom
at the end of the zombie run they do
that too where there's like it all
funnels to like a building yeah and it's
pitch black inside there's a sign that
just says crawl
and you're like all right so you get
down real low you can't see anything
and there's wires dangling all so if you
go up a little too high one of these
things touches you and it's like dude
yeah it's like jolteon it is
brutal brutal it's like it sucked i mean
obviously it's a voltage that can't
i mean i guess permanently hurts you but
like you feel it it shocks through your
body
how long was the release waiver was it
like eight pages
yeah it was a few years of solids like
yeah it was like 10 pages yeah
you know it's pretty bad that sounds uh
like an experience it's it
it sounds like interesting like i i you
know you might be watching
i feel like i know i feel like it's your
jam jake like i know you're a runner and
stuff like this is they're super fun
ride up your alley because it was super
fun like even though it was tough for me
like
by the end i felt really accomplished
and like you know we did it and got a
shirt and a headband and you know the
whole thing but it was a funny
it all goes to charity so that was it it
was worth it yeah yeah totally
yeah yeah well yeah so i got two
questions but since you brought up
charity let's talk about that real quick
um so i was trying to give you a segway
right there james yeah
it was great great natural segue um no
seriously so we just did extra life over
the weekend
um it's the first time that quarter
digital
in any way has like formally
participated in it so
hey yeah tell those guys to keep it and
hey recording
please
no we don't we don't cut anything from
the show
i have no regrets then so but seriously
um that's something we talked about
doing last year
and then you know we had the opportunity
to work together this year and you made
it happen
so i just want to say first of all like
congrats on
setting that all up um it sounds like it
was
you know like great a great success
honestly from from what we were able to
do
and and how everything went but i mean
what was it like for you personally
yeah and you've been doing extra life
for for years so i mean i'm interested
to see how you got into the whole thing
and stuff
well i mean i initially did it about
five years ago um
again studio 71 a guy named john carl
um basically just like invited people to
stop by and so i
went into his apartment just drank with
him a little bit and then played a
video games for a little while and then
and then got out of there um
and then it like became like an actual
thing um eventually i did my own
um and nico came to that one and d came
to that one
uh along with nick and carmichael um
and you guys uh kind of like pushed it
through socials and
that that was a year where like we
raised uh uh like 2500
even i'm pretty sure um and then
last year i tried to ramp it up a little
bit more i had like an actual studio and
like uh like an atom like cutting cam
between cameras and stuff like that
yeah um and uh i had freddy and
uh ren and a few other people come on
and uh push through socials but like
last year
um extra life was ddosed uh
on game day um oh really and so like
uh basically they lost like a bunch of
like potential donations
uh that would have gone towards you know
children's miracle network
uh this year they had better protections
on that
and i mean i i did it through node
um i'm the only one who stayed the 24.
dean did almost 12 of them
jordan did a like a solid amount too um
and just had people come in throughout
the day um we raised
uh the final number is eleven thousand
one hundred eighty nine dollars that's
awesome though
for children's american clubs that was
really really cool that's
pretty impressive um that's amazing
uh so i tuned in a few times and
i tuned in about 15 minutes before it
ended and you guys were at like 9
000 so what happened yes the last
15 minutes there oh man the last last 15
minutes we were like uh
oh man i guess we're just not gonna
reach our goal and then like
somebody out of the blue like donated
like a thousand
dollars just like off off the bat and i
was like
okay never mind we're going to reach our
goal blow past it
everybody donate now we're going to read
off every single donation
you're just like uh you know feigned as
much like excitement as that we possibly
could because i
had not slept in 28 hours at that point
um and and ren came in with the coffee
and and like uh some egg bites for me
to like wake me up and uh yeah
and in that time i think i completed
like tetris marathon
mode twice uh like perfect score
uh like on 26 hours of sleep
i was just like i was just hyped out of
my mind just like yeah i'm gonna clear
all these lines
red answer every question just just go
just go man
how how much tetris have you played in
your life
to be able to do that so now now this is
a thing
clint uh keeps challenging me to tetris
yeah he's like i'm gonna be going to be
too in tetris
i'm like no you're not and uh so far
we've been trading it off uh
i'm i i generally win uh slightly more
uh really than him yeah clint is like an
uber competitive guy i don't know if uh
i don't know if people know that but as
soon as he gets his
as soon as he gets his heart on
something or like his mind into
something
he immediately can't not
think about it until he's until he's
like
succeeded in in whatever his own goal
for himself is
well we've unearthed the revelation that
both clinton and i
back i want to say like five ten years
ago
i i don't know the exact same time frame
uh had
an obsession with uh tetris ds and like
uh doing the wireless play with your
friends
to like verse each other because like
that is an insanely competitive scene
and i
oh man oh i did this in college too i i
like how to i had a group
of people who like all never beat me at
tetris
and it was it was like the one thing it
was like the one game that i was
ridiculously good at i don't know why
like they also wanted to play starcraft
2 and then i would just get my ass
whipped by them but it was just like
okay
well uh do you want to play tetris um
i just i just i just happened to you
know
kind of be good at this yeah it's a
tetris game i mean
like okay so for me that's like
goldeneye 64
uh and and halo one those are those are
the two games that i can
like hold my own against almost anyone
in that
in those two games i think everybody has
like a game that they're just
intuitively stupidly good at for no
given reason
for sam it's uh what is that rainbow six
sam oh well splinter cell
we had a period there when the game
count came out it was
brief but we played for like four or
five months and
basically one nine out of ten games
i think it's just because there's no
voice chat or text chat
in the game so you have to be playing
with people you know
so yeah uh yeah to really get strategic
i hear you
yeah yeah you guys were crushing people
for for a long time it's so funny
yeah yeah um okay so i have another
question about extra life um
where did this all come from
um i mean i generally have a philosophy
that if i
can uh affect change positively then i'm
going to
use what platform i have to do that so
um that gracefully uh you guys
are did let me do that um it was really
really cool but
um ultimately it was just this thing
that i i wanted to do that that i had to
basically convince everybody else to to
hop on and and do
and everybody especially the audience
like uh
you know yeah just immediately picked up
the vibe and and uh really
really like just saw like the intent of
what we were doing and trying to make it
happen
and then um we uh
so we were able to raise 11 000 doing
that
and and and that goes to children's
miracle network
yeah and children's miracle network is
like a series of hospitals across the
country like
local to my uh hometown as one called
riley the one that i raised uh
7 4 7 500 for this year was uh
the children's miracle hospital or
children's hospital of la i think that's
the one over like on vermonters
yeah my cousin used to work there yeah
yeah it's yeah it's it's a really
cool it's a really big facility um
yeah uh yeah so i mean we
kind of spread it out all over the place
um some people uh never ended up like
actually uh showing up um
but you know i got them to make profiles
anyway and people
you know still like left donations for
those people
just like trying to get like positive
messages out like nico got one out and
then
christian uh got one out and people just
donated to them uh hoping to
to you know affect positive change um
awesome
and it went to all sorts of different
hospitals across the country
like everybody chose a different one it
was it was really really cool um awesome
yeah all right that's that's what i
liked about like the team dynamic just
like instead of us
doing like corridor digital going all
towards children's hospital la like
yeah you know rural areas have you know
bigger well first of all a children's uh
children's miracle network right now is
uh
in many ways like a coven 19 relief fund
um
because like you know it children are
more likely to be affected by it um
it you know when they're like younger um
maybe
babies yeah um so like that
a solid portion of extra life this year
was about like over 19 relief
sure um and uh so it's it's really good
to like get
like a bunch of that money out to like
rural areas uh
where you know there's like a a
generally choked points
um due to you know yeah there's
information number of factors
well in and then income and population
and
everything yeah a bunch of bunch of
factors um
that's that's awesome i'm really glad
and i feel like right now we finally
have
a big enough team to actually be able to
do it properly
um yeah like like you know with with you
and the addition of a few other people
this year
i and last year i feel like we we
finally have
the infrastructure to be able to do it
and to do it well so hopefully it's
something we can continue to do
um for for you know as long as it's a
thing
yeah i mean we're gonna we're gonna
continue to to do
like some like you know just nice things
uh here and there for like
various groups even if it doesn't
benefit uh you know
us in particular like every next week
we're shooting at a pug shelter
yeah and uh that i mean we'll call to
action on that just being like hey
help the bug shelter like it's it's it's
just uh
i mean that's the way that i approach
doing it that's gonna be different
random day
fun day do they only take pugs
uh they take pug crosses and then they
take uh
dogs that are um like
pair bonded with uh other pugs okay
because
that would be you know if they were like
a strict
you know and and you try to bring like a
half pug or like a dog that like is
associated with a pug and they're like
no sorry no not that one i'm not
yeah what do you think this is uh
it's called the pug shelter uh it's pug
it's specifically the pug shelter
because uh pugs are
very often a breed that people kind of
abandon after a few years
really do yeah like due to like their
health problems and also the fact that
they like
stop being stop being cute after like a
few years and actually become you know a
dog
right that you have to take care of so
yeah that's
that's yeah people are weird about dogs
like i i
you know i feel like you taking a dog
you know you make a commitment to that
dog and
you kind of got to keep that dog unless
you give it to somebody else who has a
good home for it
you know um sure but uh that's just me
no i totally agree it's a dog you know
it's your responsibility if you're gonna
take that on
yeah you shouldn't just like discard it
after a couple years because you're
tired of it you know
not the way i am excited to finally find
out the answer as to whether you can
teach
an old dog new tricks that does the
video
don't think about it too hard okay um
so studio 71 uh let's talk about that
for a second now
you and christian both started working
there
and what was it 2013
um so i think i was there slightly
before natalie yes
it was 2014 i was 2015 yeah sure okay
because i was there when it was still
the collective music yeah and so was i
yeah like i
i was there when they were shutting the
doors on the collective
first week yeah they were still
representing like god smack and slash
and
yeah martin lawrence it was a weird
it was a weird day seeing like the jonas
brothers just walking through the office
and then i never saw that ever happen
ever again
because they shut it down the next week
i remember when
uh we joined with them at corridor
um and uh they were still representing
music artists and they gave us tickets
to lincoln park incubus lincoln park
yeah
we were just talking about that concert
the other day were you yeah yeah
um that was the first time i ever got to
go
backstage uh at like a big show and
uh kind of see how how the how the
wheels turned
um and then they took us back john carl
actually took us backstage at wwe
which was amazing um say what you will
about the wwe
but honestly okay here's why i'm a fan
not not because i like believe the story
lines no of course but i think
that experience kind of make you a fan
because like you really got to see it
well okay so i was a fan when i was a
kid
and we were streaming and ultimate
warrior was my favorite wrestler
and we would watch wcw whenever my dad
was not at the house because he thought
it was trash tv which
it is especially for kids sure but
but the thing about it is as an adult
the thing that makes me still a fan of
it is is the production
it's the most intense insane
like high value high professional
circus literally it's a circus like
let's be honest it's a straight up
circus they go from town to town
they got the same act right they repeat
it and they expand on this
but it's it's more than that they have
writers they have merch they've got
tv they've got uh youtube they've got
every platform
they've got pay-per-view like the the
the the whole logistical like thing of
it i can't even
i can't even wrap my head around what
building blocks
are you're vince mcmahon and you're 25
years old or whatever like
what what do you do you know what
what what what i think it's it's it's
the theatrics that like
i i mean i'm not i'm not like a huge
wrestling fan but i i see it kind of
like uh
if you if you know like anything about
drag or anything like that it's just
like
something that's so ridiculously off the
top uh
and like appeals to such a specific like
niche
yeah like uh it it it's it's hard not to
like watch that and just be like oh this
is the best thing ever
it's so ridiculous it's so ridiculous
like it
and that's what makes it fun and that's
what makes it funny and stuff you know
um and not to mention it's like actually
there is an
element of sportsmanship and danger i
mean it's inherent within those matches
it's a stunt show it's a big it is it
literally is it's a huge stunt show
because
it's all set up and they're like okay
you know we know
kind of how this is going to go but we
don't know
but we're running but we're running
stunts still so you know yeah you don't
know
live stunts in front of you know i mean
it's comparable to like you know nitro
circus it's like yeah sure they know the
tricks they're gonna do and stuff but
it's like
it's live so yeah if a crash happens a
crash happens and
even nitro circus doesn't have the level
of extremities
like the the you know when it comes to
like the way that they've diversified
and monetized that business i mean
like honestly i i can't say enough good
things about it like
i know it's ridiculous and i know that
it's it's totally over the top
but as a as a business it's
it's amazing to watch you have to really
like the craft yeah yeah
yeah um so yeah you guys started there
uh 2013 2015. christian i remember when
you were right with big frame
yeah that was the show that was the
transition it was ripped
and yeah ripped it was amc and mcm but
yeah technically i wasn't ever employed
by big frame i was
mr guitar man sister company big frame
all just because you know
husband and wife duo over there and
that's when we did sync
yeah with bam yeah with bama yeah
bam oh yeah yeah rip yeah
yeah well yeah no you i mean yeah jake
you
introduced me to the youtube world
technically and because i you know 2010
we lived in the same building 2011 we
lived in the same house
and that was actually funny that you
mentioned jonas brothers natalie i was
working with the jonas brothers
for the longest time um turned that
internship into a job and then
that like just fell off and jake was
like well hey my management company i
can introduce you
which was big frame at the time which
introduced me to joe which introduced me
to the whole world of youtube
and then uh yeah it was joe to
then studio 71 and and yeah that whole
that whole
it does sometimes get to me like how
ridiculously small of a world like this
ended up being like
and i i just came out of like nowhere
like
it from indiana like five years ago and
just kind of ended up in the middle of
it and everybody knows each other and
it's
it's pretty great yeah i think that's
one thing
i don't know if people know uh kind of
on the outside looking in but
you know it it it might seem like oh hey
you know um who who's this or who's that
or you know but but oftentimes the
the connections and the the
relationships that people make
uh lead to to other things in the future
and so like
you know um natalie you're talking going
back uh
at least five years i think she's six at
this point yeah
yeah um and then you know christian
that's like uh
well dude i've known you guys for a
decade now which is crazy
you know yeah cause like even before i
was working in youtube like
you would invite me down to hunter
street just as my roommate
right and so i met sammy because i just
hang out and
play with foam swords and i'm like
learning that you guys make videos
and stuff see it all goes back to the
swords you know what i mean it really
does come full circle
uh so i i really think we should make
that uh
japanese sword i mean maybe
it's probably going to be ridiculously
expensive oh yeah i guess i was going to
say have you done the research
i've done the research okay pretty penny
what if we do this
what if we do this we we we figure out
how much it is to make
and then we factor in uh flight and
lodging
and we pick one subscriber
from the site quarterdigital.com
one person who backed the project and we
if we fly
bring them out here to their house oh we
go there
yeah we fly to their house and do the
ceremony from kill bill
where i present him the sword so we
follow the process of making it but we
gotta
factor in the cost of going to gift it
to that person because yes
i can i can truly say this is the finest
sword i've ever constructed
yeah if you man encounter god god will
be cut
so and then not only do we get an
amazing
like node video of just doing that part
of it but then we have a sick build
video
that is like for the subs and we have
maybe maybe it's even a series of videos
just for the site i think that would i
have a i have a full
list of things that are too expensive
for my budget that i would love to build
here we go this is the next green light
show for you
let's figure it out uh if you guys like
that idea honestly let us know in the
comments because we would totally do
that
um and it might be pretty yeah it might
take a few months
but uh you know um it'll happen
by the way the other green light shows
are in progress functional filmmaking is
almost ready to shoot on friday
everything's there we're getting it
happening setting up the studio right
now to film functional filmmaking
yeah all you website subscribers it's
all coming
yep and then yep yeah son of a dungeon
son of a dunk is gonna be ready to go
pretty quickly here now too
i think we're yeah i'm gonna bust it out
right away in january because
all the tech is ready for it we just uh
yeah just gotta
plan a couple of few hour sessions for
some dnb
it's nice to see how the other shows are
coming along they are
they are we're gonna have to make one's
people or that's gonna probably be ready
to go in like march probably
and uh i mean all these videos we're
doing in the studio right now are kind
of working towards that
also shout out to danielle working on
like
awesome so to to talk about a few other
developments on the site i know we
always talk about the subscribers on
this podcast but
that's because it's the trutans so here
before you hop into this
at this point yeah you got my kid my
kids are starting to
go a little wild right now i think i
have to bounce here okay go
go do daddy duty i'm gonna go i'm just
gonna go
let's take a moment of silence for sam's
sam
sam's time away fatherhood calls
all right okay all right see you buddy
on we will uh we will so
see you sam see you soon so uh
phase two that's what we're moving into
next year
um we've gotten a lot of questions about
uh
hey can i buy more producer points we've
gotten
all these different so first one that's
one of the big ones
short answer is yes we are going to come
up with a feature where you can buy
more producer points but it is gonna be
a cap
because we don't in it so it'll be like
packages you can buy x amount of points
for x
amount of dollars up to a certain amount
because we don't want to
we don't want like one angel investor
type thing yeah yeah we don't want to
over influence the shows
it should ultimately feel like another
patreon kind of platform instead of
like you know somebody just donating
like exactly yeah
so that's a good point the thing that
we're the thing that also distinguishes
it from
like a traditional kickstarter and the
reason why it's now currently viable for
us and
and the the way that we can scale it
over time
is is because of uh the recurring
subscription model so when a show gets
financed that means
there's enough subscribers who have been
on the site for long enough to make that
show
uh affordable to to create yeah then
the other side of that is then those
people can
stay when those people stay on the site
after that show gets made
you know all of a sudden have the
ability to take that extra money
and to put it back into the site so that
you can then
make bigger shows hire a few more people
and start to
scale the thing properly over time now
that takes time
but that is that is a key distinction so
we don't want to
just like offer hey 15 000 points
and then one person one time and then
agree yeah because that's not
really the model that that that's
functional but we will
have the ability to purchase more
producer points um
yeah and then we're gonna do uh green
light days
probably maybe maybe up to four times a
year
where it's a it's a special where uh
if you sign up if you're if you're
listening on the podcast or you're
watching stuff on youtube we'll put out
a video and we'll say
on youtube hey uh guys you have seven
days to sign up for the site
the the eighth day is green light day
meaning that if you sign up
by that day your producer points are
worth double
uh if you sign up in that period or if
you upgrade in that period
um and then we're going to introduce a
premium tier because we have all these
people on patreon right now that was
sort of like
you know that was our all the people on
patreon like
i seriously we should have them all
we should give them like a dinner or
something i don't know i don't know yeah
because what once because the plan is
eventually like
we want to offer the same thing that we
have at patreon
just through the site but patreon was
the thing that sort of started it all
and it's the thing that kept us going
for a long time and it's the thing that
we sort of
took the idea of that model and built it
into the site
and so we have a huge amount of like
i guess there's a huge amount of emotion
really for for that
and so i want to make sure that people
can continue to get those types of
benefits if they want
so we're going to offer a premium
membership tier uh
which effectively is is a carryover from
patreon and then
we'll obviously ask all the people on
patreon to
to to move over um in eventually
integrating
patreon into the site um so that's
that's another thing and then obviously
we're gonna drop more shows
uh on green light we're gonna have more
ideas
i would love to see the next round of
but
what we come up with i mean the green
light shows there's a lot of people
around here who like have like some
really solid ideas that
you know maybe you'll actually see yeah
yeah exactly so that would
be that's that's gonna take you know
probably
i would say probably two to three months
to like actually build out the new slate
of shows and then
introduce it with trailers and all the
you know bells and whistles that go
along with that
so that's probably like a spring sort of
thing
um and then uh there's a few other
things
oh uh people have been asking can you
open this up to other creators
can other creators give you an idea uh
again
yes on that um but we want to make sure
that we get our we get our foundation
right
first like we want to do the shows that
have already been greenlit
we want to like put a few more in and
then
and and really like get a good
flow of work going so that when we ask
other people when we go out to like
say we go to freddy or you know whoever
uh some of the some of the other people
that we've been creating with for a
while and we say hey do you have an idea
we don't want to be we want to be able
to follow through on that
with an infrastructure that's already in
place and so that's just going to take a
little bit of time to build but that's
that's the goal um so
i don't know yeah it's it's kind of
amazing that we didn't think about doing
this sooner i'm super glad that scott
uh came along and and actually
has put in the time to to make it
possible with us
um and then obviously having griffin uh
you know to be able to curate and
produce all the
graphics everything yeah the whole
aesthetic you see on the website
right now it's good to have people like
that so
yeah there's a ton still that we're
going to be doing with it and uh
you know if you start if you signed up
right when we put it out
you know now is coming into december and
then
into the beginning of the year that's
when we're going to start to prove out
some of these green light shows um so
again we'll be talking all about it as
it comes out but i'm super excited if
you can't tell from me
blabbing on about it for the last 10
minutes i'm excited it's gonna be yeah
all good stuff i'm excited to see
carmichael back in the office we're
getting functional filmmaking going he's
ready it's
really nice to have him back yeah he's
back from the dead back
so our shining boy yeah it's definitely
some of the most exciting stuff we got
going on right now so
hell yeah um okay well hey uh
this was awesome this was super fun yeah
i know we had sam's crying baby so
thanks to gideon for the uh
for the cameo yeah thanks for popping in
and
yeah i wonder what age you'll be when
you're going through all this content
and watching it
i know do you guys ever do that do you
ever go back and watch old videos oh
totally dude i mean that's funny about
our line of work it's like
we have a vlogs and videos that are
basically a scrapbook of
who we were back in the day you know
even from back i'm like i watched the
gravity gun bts a long time ago i was
like dude
i was just like a producer for hire on
this show and now we're here
doing it all you know so it's yeah it's
crazy to all come full circle
hell yeah all right
it's about time to play us out ladies
and gentlemen thanks for sticking around
subscribe to quarter cast if you're not
already
good to be on the cast thank you natalie
been a while
for joining us thank you christian
for joining us and sam
wherever you are come on back
come on back and sam wherever you are
i hope you're putting your babies to
sleep cause i gotta do the same thing
right now thanks everybody see you later